les patrouilles de la police municipale
de lamentin sont sur le terrain
uniquement durant la journée
49 agents municipaux tous services
confondus sont en permanence en contact
avec la population de cette ville de
4500 habitants
ils sont au quotidien informés les
événements nocturnes est vrai qu on
n'est pas présent de nuit donc c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas le droit sont pas
effectivement ce nombre d'effectifs mais
on a quand même des remontées de la
population et des fois se plaignent de
n'avoir pas vu les services de police
quand les appels et s'est demandé
d'éteindre le feu et si au coeur j'aime
plutôt elles sont sollicitées pour un
différend entre particuliers à cause
d'un feu des policiers municipaux qui
activent dans bourg de la commune et
notamment dans les zones très sensibles
médiation verbalisation font partie de
leur quotidien
bien qu'il dispose depuis pour les 6 ans
le centre de supervision urbaine leur
champ d'action est limité à un certain
niveau police et gendarmerie prennent le
relais centre ville on avait un petit
trafic qui était bien installé donc on a
avec les images pu les transmettre sur
réquisition à l'obliger donc on a pu
régler ce problème
on a aussi de nombreuses acquisitions
qui nous arrive de la gendarmerie et de
la police nationale sous des affaires
qui sont en cours donc que ça aussi on
les emmène ce que je déplore c'est qu'on
n'est pas toujours le retour des
éléments fournis la récente déclaration
le secrétaire général d'alliance police
de martiniquais sur notre plateau
concernant le manque d'effectifs et de
moyens de la police nationale ne laisse
pas indifférent le maire de la commune
on constate aujourd'hui sur l'inventaire
complet au fort de france aussi leur
connaissance de deux phénomènes qui sont
liées d'abord le trafic de drogue
extrêmement important avec des poches
sur le l'amateur nous connaissons et que
nous avons déjà identifié transmis
l'information à la police nationale et à
partir de ce trafic de drogue se
développe le trafic d'armes et on a déjà
entendu des annonces dans la police deux
caches d'armes déjà été identifiés ils
voulaient nous sommes dans une situation
mettant type extrêmement dangereuse
compte tenu de cette nouvelle vague
d'homicides place en martinique en tête
de ce triste palmarès des faits divers
le maire exige maintenant certaines
dispositions
je veux d'engagement de l'état sur des
moyens qui nous seront données désormais
pour produire les politiques de ville
pour anticiper les dérives et
accompagner les du cash et la formation
des jeunes
je suis favre à la commission d'athlètes
qui viendra travailler sur le trafic de
drogue et le trafic d'armes sur la
martinique
parce que ça ne peut plus continuer
comme ça aujourd'hui les bandits sont
beaucoup mieux armé que la police
nationale
c'est un problème en ce moment de
nombreux groupes de réflexion se penche
très sérieusement sur cette
problématique
enfin par un communiqué de presse le
préfet précise que les fonctionnaires de
police de la direction départementale de
la sécurité publique sont pleinement
engagés 7 jours sur 7 et 24 heures sur
24 pour garantir la sécurité des
martiniquais au lamentin et à fort de
france